he escrito aquí la definición formal de
lo que es una derivada parcial con
respecto de x de una función f que tiene
dos variables verdad y lo que quiero
hacer ahora es construir una definición
de lo que es la derivada direccional de
esta misma función en la dirección de
algún vector b así que por ejemplo vamos
a considerar algún vector b digamos
puede ser arbitrario verdad es eso en
esencia es un vector en el espacio de
entradas y voy a hacer un diagrama para
tratar de recordar cómo es que hemos
estado construyendo nuestras derivadas
parciales verdad entonces digamos que
aquí tengo el espacio de entradas que en
esencia es el plano x xi y en este
espacio tenemos un punto digamos el
punto a ve verdad entonces en nuestra
función f de alguna forma lo que hace es
transformar nuestro espacio de entradas
a este espacio de salidas que en este
caso es la recta verdad porque sólo
tenemos una
una variable de salida verdad y digamos
si nuestra función f lo que hace es
mandar este punto digamos a este punto
de acá sobre la recta entonces la
derivada parcial digamos consiste en
considerar un pequeño empujoncito en la
dirección x verdad y ver cómo es que
este pequeño empujoncito afecta digamos
cómo afecta nuestra salida a partir de
la función f verdad entonces por ejemplo
aquí representaría un cambio negativo
verdad así que si nosotros tomamos
digamos una h la h digamos representaría
este pequeño empujoncito que damos en la
dirección x verdad entonces si tomamos
esta aquí también algunas otras personas
lo denotan como delta equis pero bueno
ya mí se me hace mucho más fácil cómo
tomar una verdad entonces esto lo
pensamos como nuestro empujoncito y al
pensar en cómo influye esto en la
función al cambiar sólo nuestra variable
la primera variable aquí en esencia lo
que estamos haciendo en el numerador es
calcular el cambio que sufre nuestra
función f verdad y estamos haciendo la
proporción con el cambio que hacemos en
x muy bien entonces podemos en realidad
reescribir esta definición en términos
vectoriales de la siguiente forma
tendremos la derivada parcial de nuestra
función con respecto a x digamos ahora
no en el punto a como ves sino en el
vector a el vector a sería justamente el
vector que representa a esta al ala de
verdad entonces esta derivada será
simplemente el límite vamos a poner lo
distinto el límite cuando nuestra
variable h tiende a cero verdad que
representa nuestro empujoncito verdad de
nuestra función f evaluada en el vector
más aquí tenemos que hacer nuestro
cambio verdad tendremos que hacer
nuestro empujoncito entonces será h
veces el vector y donde este vector y se
suele digamos suele representar al
vector que tiene entradas 1 0 verdad es
el vector unitario en la dirección del
eje x muy bien y luego restamos nuestra
función en el punto a verdad si se dan
cuenta estamos simplemente copiando lo
de arriba pero con notación de vectores
y luego dividimos entre h verdad entre
nuestro pequeño empujoncito y cuando lo
escribimos así es mucho más claro cómo
podemos extender esta idea digamos ahora
cuando nos movemos en otra dirección
verdad pues ahora toda la información
digamos de cómo nos estamos moviendo
está contenida en este vector verdad en
este vector que estamos escribiendo con
él digamos con la y verdad así que esto
nos da una idea de cómo podríamos
extender esta definición para
derivadas direccionales entonces nuestra
derivada direccional de nuestra función
en la dirección del vector b digamos en
el punto a es importante poner donde lo
estamos haciendo será igual al límite
cuando h tiende a 0 h tiende a 0 de
nuestra función evaluada en el punto o
el o más bien en el vector a más
h veces ahora multiplicando al vector b
que es la dirección en la que nos
estamos moviendo en este caso era el
vector y en este caso puede ser
cualquier vector b y le restamos la
función evaluada en la entonces esto nos
da el cambio en h y hay que dividir
entre el cambio pero en este caso
estaríamos interpretándolo como el
cambio en la dirección del vector de
verdad entonces simplemente tenemos aquí
la definición formal de lo que es la
derivada direccional y en realidad es
mucho más fácil recordarla cuando
utilizamos vectores muy bien así que
veamos cómo se vería geométricamente
esta idea vamos a borrar vamos a borrar
esto que tenemos aquí
carlos y en vez de poner el punto a b en
realidad vamos a representarlo con el
vector
entonces quitamos esto digamos vamos a
vamos a admitir esta flechita que
habíamos pintado entonces este punto de
aquí lo podríamos representar con el
vector a verdad entonces va a ser una
flecha que va del origen a este punto
verdad ahí lo tenemos y digamos
podríamos considerar el vector b que a
lo mejor digamos no tiene ni por qué ir
en la dirección de x ni en la dirección
de ye puede ser como una especie de
combinación de ambos y ahora vamos a
rescatar este vector b digamos con un
factor de escala h verdad entonces aquí
estaríamos considerando h veces y el
vector b y una vez que tenemos esto
estaríamos considerando como digamos
influye esto en la salida de nuestra
función entonces a lo mejor ahora
tenemos que influye en esta pequeña
dirección verdad y quizás estés viendo
que esto lo podemos ver
exactamente como la pendiente de una
gráfica verdad pero eso lo veremos en el
próximo vídeo entonces en resumen lo que
estamos haciendo es calcular la
proporción que hay entre el cambio en
digamos en nuestra salida dada por la
función f y el cambio que hacemos en la
dirección de nuestro vector de verdad y
luego tomamos el límite cuando h tiende
a cero es decir hacer este pequeño
cambio cada vez o este pequeño
empujoncito cada vez más y más pequeño
sin embargo hay que tener mucho cuidado
verdad porque si nosotros digamos
escalamos este vector digamos que que no
consideramos el vector b sino dos veces
el vector de verdad entonces aquí en la
definición tendríamos que poner un 2
también y entonces vamos a tener el
doble de cambio verdad porque aquí en
vez de tener a veces b tendríamos h
veces 2 b verdad entonces vamos a tener
el doble de cambio de hecho algunas
personas prefieren cambiar la definición
original
les he puesto aquí y poner mejor en el
denominador el digamos la norma o el
módulo del vector b para que al
reescalar no se modifique digamos la
derivada direccional y en realidad sólo
le importe la dirección pero a mí no me
gusta mucho esto yo creo que que hay
algo de utilidad en esta definición
original que yo les había dado sin el
módulo o la norma debe y podemos dar una
muy buena interpretación de esto pero ya
nos adentraremos más en este detalle
digamos en futuros vídeos aquí solo la
idea sólo era ver la definición formal
de la derivada direccional bueno nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo